foreign
once again so this is a real good one uh
that we are talking about today this is
actually a movie that I saw several
years ago um but I had been wanting to
re-watch it again to uh talk about it
for this series and this is the 2016
movie the void now this is a very very
uh well-regarded lovecraftian film it's
Canadian
uh and it was written and directed by
Stephen kostansky and Jeremy Gillespie
and I believe that most of the funding
from this movie came from Indiegogo I
think they made like 83 000 or something
like that I don't know if that was the
entirety of the budget uh if it was wow
because they uh did a really good job I
don't know if they had some money from
other sources as well so I'm gonna say
that um just like kind of a lot of
horror films indie or otherwise uh from
the past you know decade or so uh it has
a very heavy 1980s influence
um and you know that's a good thing
generally it has really really good uh
very very splattery like practical
effects and they look terrific and it
does kind of reference a lot of
um 80s era horror films like it's not
ripping them off but or even homaging
them really but it does kind of have a
lot of touchstones that were used a lot
in 80s horror and I'm not real sure
about this it seems like and I've
watched it the second time today
and I was kind of like it almost seems
like it's set in the 1980s
um because it doesn't seem like anybody
has cell phones and like some of the
cars like the car models look older but
I don't think the year is mentioned in
it unless I totally spaced out and like
missed it um it's not important to the
story or anything like that I just
thought that was kind of like
interesting it almost seems like it's
not in any particular time period you
know what I'm saying now this discussion
is gonna have uh spoilers so if you
haven't seen the void probably you
should go and watch it because it's
really good and you should go watch it
um actually at the moment as of this
recording
um you know you can rent it someplace
like YouTube and stuff like that
obviously but I actually watched it on
Crackle for free with ads so you know if
you don't want to spend money on it or
anything like that you can actually if
you have crackle you can actually watch
it on there with ads
so the movie starts out
with this woman it's like a great
opening sequence because you're just
immediately like what the [__] is going
on with this this woman is like running
out of a house with two armed men like
running after her and she's like
freaking out and screaming as you would
obviously and they shoot her in the back
um and then another dude comes out of
the house like but he doesn't get shot
like he manages to avoid being killed
and he just takes off into the woods
like surrounding the house and then like
so the two Shooters like just come out
in the yard where the lady is laying
there like she's still alive and she's
trying to like crawl away and stuff even
though she's been shot in the back and
they just kind of like very I don't even
know if I'd say casually but they do
kind of casually just kind of like set
her on fire like while she's screaming
and stuff so you're just kind of like
okay well that is quite that's quite an
opening sequence all right you've got my
attention
so then we cut to
the main character who is this kind of
small town police officer named Daniel
Carter and he sees the wounded guy like
that ran into the woods earlier like
kind of crawling out of the woods and he
hurries over there to help him because
he doesn't know anything that's been
going on
so he takes this guy the guy's name is
James he takes him to this Hospital like
the nearest one now the hospital that he
takes him to only has like this really
small like skeleton staff because there
was a fire that broke out there recently
so the few remaining staff members are
going to be moved to another hospital
like shortly but they're kind of stuck
at this you know empty Backwater
hospital that's damaged like for the
time being so when he gets there the
only other people at this Hospital are a
nurse named Allison who also happens to
be Daniel's ex-wife because like I said
this is a small town uh there's another
nurse that are named Beverly there's
like a trainee named Kim an older doctor
named Dr Powell there's a patient in
there like in one of the rooms named
cliff and then in the waiting room
there's this pregnant girl named Maggie
and her grandfather Ben who was like you
know come with her to help her out or
whatever so almost immediately after
Daniel the cop like brings James into
the hospital to have him looked at
things start getting a little bit weird
at this [__] Hospital
Beverly
um actually goes into some weird kind of
Trance it appears and ends up killing
Cliff with a scalpel like sticking his
eyeball and stuff like that and then
like she cuts the skin off her own face
and then like kind of lunges at Daniel
and he ends up having to shoot her
because she looks like she's gonna stab
him
so not long after that like this state
trooper arrives whose name is Mitchell
who's played by Art hindel actually
who's in like a [__] ton of stuff
so he was actually looking for James the
guy that the cop brought in because he's
investigating what he calls a bloodbath
like out at the house we saw at the
beginning obviously where they should
set the woman on fire and everything
but then suddenly like none of the
phones in the place seem to be able to
reach the outside world Daniel goes
outside to try the radio and his police
cruiser but that doesn't work either and
while he's out there he's set upon by
this creepy looking person who's wearing
this kind of white full body burka type
situation like a you know just this full
body like costume with like a black
triangle like over the face now so
before he can even like figure out like
who the [__] this is or what the hell is
going on
um the hospital becomes like surrounded
by all of these creepy people like in
this outfit in these outfits and they
seem to have been summoned by this kind
of weird horn-like noise that's coming
from the sky now Daniel is actually
wounded so he goes back in there and
they're all freaking out but meanwhile
back in the hospital the group have
discovered that the one-time nurse
Beverly the one one who tore her face
off and everything has
there's really no delicate way to say
this she's turned into like essentially
like a big tentacle monster okay um you
know so they're just kind of like huh
well you don't you don't see that every
day now the two shooters from the first
scene that one that's the one that's at
the girl the woman on fire
um their names are Vincent and his son
Simon they come to the hospital uh in
order to finish the job they started
which was to kill James that's who they
were chasing
now they do seem to know about this
whole situation vis-a-vis like people
transforming into monsters but they
don't seem to know much else uh but at
this point it seems they're not really
taking any chances because they're like
look we've seen a couple people like
turn into that we don't know anything
any of you [__] so we're just gonna
like kill you all and let God sort it
out you know and then after this like
the movie almost takes on the feel of
like a Siege type flick like you know
like the mist or Assault on Precinct 13
or something like like vaguely you know
what I mean
um because all of the characters are
trapped inside the hospital by like
these white robed cult people outside
and they're also really uneasy about the
people that they're locked in the
building with because these are
essentially like you know a bunch of
strangers basically
um because any of them could turn into
these lovecraftian technical murder
Critters like at any moment apparently
also throughout the movie Daniel has
been having visions of this like vast
featureless void you know title drop in
which this like massive Black Pyramid
just kind of looms on the horizon it's
really cool looking like the visuals so
as The Story Goes On we actually figure
out that this is indeed another
dimension and much like in Hellraiser
you know the Clive Barker movie somebody
has figured out how to access this other
dimension in order to further his own
goals let's call it that so the culprit
the person that did that is spoiler
alert
Dr Powell like the elderly nefarious
[__] in the hospital it turns
out they discover that he had been
experimenting with opening the door to
this void for some time because he
believed that it would well he wanted to
become immortal for one thing because
don't they all but he also thought that
it would bring his daughter Sarah back
from the dead
now later in the movie like the
characters while they're kind of like
looking around in the hospital and stuff
they stumble across this weird
sub-basement that's like not supposed to
be there and it has all of these just
malformed human Horrors in it like one
of the characters even just says this is
Hell or something like just because
there's all these like monstrous people
um and these you find out are Dr
Powell's failed experiments that I guess
he's keeping around for shits and
giggles I'm not really sure so the fire
that ravaged the hospital the reason
that there was only a skeleton staff to
start with start with was also Dr
Powell's doing you find out because he
was lurking around down there you know
tampering in God's domain and stuff like
that and I guess like a fire got started
and [__] happens you know you also find
out that the pregnant girl the teenager
in the waiting room Maggie was actually
impregnated by Dr Powell himself
and that her baby is going to be the
conduit for the return of Sarah although
I will note that he didn't tell her that
that's exactly what was going to happen
you know what I mean so she's a little
bit surprised when she finds out how
that shit's gonna go down
um Daniel's ex-wife Allison also gets
transformed into this baby maker thing
like for the hell to mention you know
what I mean like there's all these
[__] tentacles and stuff and um he
actually ends up having to like kill or
like to put her out of her misery you
know what I mean and this is like really
sad because
um the reason that they divorced was
because she had a miscarriage and like
they couldn't deal with it and stuff
like that so that kind of makes the
whole thing like a lot more poignant you
know so at the end of the movie like
after pretty much everybody dies uh Dr
Powell who now is skinless looking like
[__] Frank from Hellraiser he tells
Daniel that he can have Allison and his
dead kid back if he accepts death and
you're not entire really sure what he
means by this he says okay but then he
like tackles you know Mr skinless no
flesh dude and they both fall into the
void so at the end like Daniel and
Allison are shown standing alone in the
void from his earlier visions and
there's like nobody else around it's
just like this vast like emptiness with
like little mountains and like this big
triangle and stuff like that so I'm
gonna say like as independent horror
films go this was pretty [__]
ambitious I gotta say uh and I admit
that I was extremely impressed with it
especially after my second viewing like
I really liked it a lot the first time I
saw it a couple years ago but like
watching it again today I got like a lot
more appreciation for it it kind of
plays like something of a mashup between
maybe Hellraiser the Mist the thing
Prince of Darkness
um the beyond the Lucio Fortune movie
especially like the end kind of reminded
me of that um and obviously there's like
a huge heaping helping of uh HP
Lovecraft in there like for good measure
the first time I watched it I think I
found the plot a little bit hard to
follow but I think it was like kind of
clearer the second time now the exact
nature of the cult like surrounding the
void and the exact end game of what Dr
Powell was up to were kind of left a
little bit ambiguous but even though um
I kind of feel like the movie made up
for this kind of unwillingness to like
completely explain Itself by just being
really I mean exceptionally entertaining
it's really fast fast paced like I said
it just kind of hits the ground running
and really doesn't stop
um and it had like just amazing amazing
like Gore effects um you know the
creature designs and [__] like that and
the Gru and everything like that which
is it looked amazing and all of it was
practical
um the acting is also fantastic which is
really good because you kind of get a
little bit of an emotional attachment at
least to some of the characters
especially like the main character now
you know I even though it's obviously
like an amalgam of a bunch of different
80s horror flicks like the ones that I
just brought up and maybe a couple other
ones but it never really feels like a
retread though because it really has its
own original Vibe going on so yeah if
you haven't seen it I really highly
highly recommend this movie especially
if you're a fan of like 80s Cosmic
horror like you know if like John
Carpenter movies or Stuart Gordon or
somebody like that and I think this is
easily one of the best lovecraftian
films ever made so that will do it for
this flickers of fear hope you guys
enjoyed it please remember to like share
subscribe comment and all of that other
good stuff and I will see you again on
the next one bye